let's learn a little bit about just how
a plain vanila Bank works so let's say
that I'm an entrepreneur and I see a
problem out there in the world you have
all of these hardworking people they you
know whatever they do doctors lawyers
engineers construction workers whatever
they might do they have they work they
provide services to each other and they
have savings right so they right now
they're just you know whatever they're
putting them they're burying it in their
back yard so you know savings and
they're just collecting there right that
that that quote-unquote money is doing
nothing they've they've provide some
good they've provided some goods and
services to someone else those people
gave them something whether it's gold or
a green piece of paper that essentially
says this gold or this green piece of
paper entitles you to some future goods
and services and those people said oh
that's a useful thing that I have let me
just put it into my mattress so whatever
the world there's this pool of savings
and let's say there's this other pool of
entrepreneurs and they have a bunch of
really good ideas for projects they're
like you know what if I could just get
let me put this your projects or
investments projects or investments
investments so let's say you know let's
say that there's some there's some other
entrepreneur he says boy you know what I
have no claims on any goods and
resources but I have an idea I have an
idea that if I could get a bunch of
people to dig canals to the crops that
we'll be able to grow more crops and
grow it throughout the year and and
we'll all be richer because we'll all
have more food and that's that's a true
good and service in its best sense but
how am I going to get these people to
build this ditch for me I mean I can I I
could maybe promise them in the future
that once all of this is done I can do
something give them more food but that's
not the way it works no one's willing to
work for me unless they can feel very
secure that they're going to get
something in return so we have an
interesting problem here you have a
bunch of people who have already
provided good
and services to the world and the world
has given them trinkets whether it's
gold coins or paper money let's just say
it's gold right and I want to make this
point because everyone always talks
about gold is if it's something special
as if it's this as if it really
represents wealth while paper money
really does not represent wealth and
that's just doctor there's nothing about
gold gold is not useful other than the
fact that it is pretty that's the only
thing that makes gold useful actually
it's pretty and it's hard to counterfeit
paper money not so pretty but it has
other advantages it's lighter and at
least the paper money we use now is is
not so easy to counterfeit so I always
want to make that you know people always
somehow feel that gold is is somehow
better than paper money and then we'll
talk about in the future about inflation
and deflation and you know the fact that
there is a constraint on how much gold
can be produced but you can print money
but we'll talk about that a little bit
so in our modern world that savings are
these green pieces of paper but let's
say we're talking about you know some
primitive culture and they're using gold
so we perform a bunt a bunch of people
perform a bunch of goods and services
and they get these they get these little
coins and these coins are essentially
this society's way of agreeing if you
have one of these coins in the future if
you give this coin to someone else
they'll do something for you and you
know how much of that coin you have to
give for them to do it based on supply
and demand and price whatever these
projects I say wow if I only had if I
only had some way of convincing someone
to dig a canal it would be hugely
beneficial and it will create wealth or
dig and dig irrigation ditches but how
do I do that well if I had gold or if I
had these little coins I could give
these Peas coins to these people they
would dig a dig the irrigation ditch and
then I could charge I don't know people
the service of using my or maybe you
know I'll charge people access to water
and then I could essentially generate a
return but how do I do that well what if
I could borrow some of these people
right these people have these units of
goods and services called a gold coin if
I could borrow some of their money and
use it to pay people that will
that will essentially do the good and
service or do the new project then I'll
generate wealth and then I could share
it with these people maybe in the form
of some type of interest well you know
it's it's very hard in a vacuum for
these people to evaluate these projects
and maybe these projects they don't
require just part of the savings of one
person they require the savings of a
thousand people because it's a large
project it's also hard for these people
to evaluate who has a good project and
it's hard for these people to evaluate
who has savings in fact if I have
savings if I'm if I've buried a bunch of
stuff in my backyard or in my mattress I
don't want to advertise it that's just
going to make people come in and rob me
so I'm a third entrepreneur and I see an
opportunity for a business and I call
that business a bank and so what is a
bank going to do what is my bank when
you do well let's just let's just talk
about it from the bare-bones how am I
going to start my business I'm actually
I'm actually one of one of these
entrepreneurs let's say I have some
savings just to make it simple so I
don't have to go into this pool so let's
say I have a million gold coins of
saving let's say it's a million dollars
let me draw my balance sheet so let's
say I have this is my balance sheet and
balance sheets as you see they were
useful even in primitive cultures so
that's my balance sheet and let's say
initially well let's say initially my
balance sheet I drew but actually let me
let me draw my initial balance sheet
let's say my initial balance sheet is I
put in a million let me just draw it I
put in a million dollars of my gold
coins so let's just say it's a million
gold oh I'll say a million dollars just
because we're used to been a million
dollars and that could you could say of
a gold coin is worth $1 so it's a
million gold coins we know that that's
not true anymore
and I use that essentially to build this
big structure of solid stone that looks
really safe and Lynn
really secure so I use it essentially
just build a big vault right I'll do
brown for the vault so this is my equity
right and I use it to build a vault a
big nice fancy looking building so I
actually draw the building it has
pillars in the front it really looks
like something it looks like an old
Greek or Roman temple and I think that's
not that's not an accidental appearance
so I build this nice-looking
building that people would feel
comfortable keeping their money and that
could actually be safe for for
safekeeping and I tell everyone look at
I have this nice this nice big building
instead of having your money insecure in
your backyard or your bed why don't you
put your savings in this building and if
you ever need it you can come and get it
and on top of that I'm going to pay you
to keep your money with me so everyone
says oh that's a good deal and Sal's
trustworthy in that more than Sal that
building looks even more trustworthy
because it looks like a Greek temple so
everyone puts their savings with me and
let's say that that is I don't know
let's say that that is ten million
dollars of savings in my village have a
fairly wealthy village so that's ten
million dollars of deposits this is a
liability for me right why is it a
liability because I owe that to other
people though they're giving it to me
for safekeeping so this is my
liabilities liabilities this is my
equity if I had multiple if it wasn't
just me if there was ten shareholders
each of us would have one-tenth of this
but at the time Allah this is a sole
proprietorship so this is my equity this
is my building so what I'm running a
business here right I'm not doing this
as some type of nonprofit or or charity
work so what am I going to do with this
ten million of deposits well I told
people that they can take the money at
any time if it you know I'm taking their
money safe keeping if they put it in and
then one day they can't get their money
back they're going to be very suspicious
of me so I have to keep some of the
money set aside there's a lot you know
this could be amongst three or four
thousand people so in any given day not
everyone's got hole or hopefully not
everyone's going to pull their money out
their money in but I need to keep some
cash reserves in case people want their
money back
so I need to keep some of that 10
million in cash so let me do that in I
don't know magenta so let's let me say I
want to keep 10% of it in cash so I'm
going to keep 1 million dollars in cash
and then I have nine million dollars
left that I can hopefully put to
productive use and what I do with that 9
million dollars is I loan it out to
people who have really good projects or
investments so 9 million in loans that's
an asset right I give that money to
someone else they owe me 9 million
dollars I'm essentially borrowing 10
million keeping 1 million aside and
paying out 9 million dollars in loans
and you know they could be a bunch of
different projects I'll you know it's
not they could be a hundred I'm not just
giving 9 million dollars to one person
I'm diversifying a bunch across a bunch
of different projects so the natural
question is how am I making money
well these in these loans I'm hopefully
putting them that you know build
irrigation ditches or build factories or
do whatever something that actually is
an investment that creates more value
than it needed to start up so I can
actually charge interest and that
interest should be a cut of that value
that's being created so let's say that I
charge 10% on this money so I'm charging
10% and just for the sake of it let's
say I invest really well and no one
defaults I'd do it this is I'm the first
bank so I get all of the best
investments so I'm getting 10% and for
their money well you know these people
not only do they get to keep their money
in this nice safe deposit but I'm also
paying them 5% I'm also paying them 5%
so how much money do I make in a year
well I'm I'm making 10% on this 9
million dollars so what is that that's
nine hundred thousand dollars a year
nine hundred thousand dollars a year I'm
bringing in and how much am I paying out
every year well five percent of ten
million I'm paying out five hundred
thousand dollars so interest income nine
hundred thousand dollars interest
expense five hundred thousand that Nets
me four hundred
and let's say I pay another I don't know
100,000 for salaries and for security
guards and all of that so essentially
I'm netting $300,000 so I'm netting
$300,000 I'll do it a little more detail
in the next video but if you look at a
big picture I put a million dollars in
and every year I'm making three hundred
thousand dollars by providing the
service by matching up the savings with
good investments and everyone benefits
the pie is getting bigger because these
are real investments that are going to
benefit my village and of course these
people benefit because they get
safekeeping for their accounts and their
money is actually growing they're
actually participating in this in this
capital investment anyway see you in the
next video